Disney and Marvel Studios are certainly
not the only companies scrambling to
juggle release schedules and production
timelines in the year of the play but
they may have the most complicated task
ahead of them thanks to the complexity
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
while movies like no time to die and
Wonder Woman 1984 can probably survive a
little disruption in their release
schedules Disney depends on its MCU
projects hitting their cues in order to
preserve the integrity of the
overarching story that links all the
series and films thus the bad but
predictable news that came from Disney
on April 3rd is especially tough for
Marvel phase 4 let's break it down
rewinding a bit in mid-march 2020 came
the news that production on the Falcon
and the Winter Soldier in Prague had
been halted due to government measures
in the Czech Republic intended to stem
the spread of the coronavirus then as it
became clear that movie theaters won't
be opening back up anytime soon Disney
was forced to reevaluate the upcoming
release dates for some of its biggest
films here's the rough the change is
that the mouse house announced on April
3rd don't just impact April and May
movies the effects on the MCU ripple all
the way out to 2020 - isn't it beautiful
the world beyond time infill scheduling
changes often have cascading
consequences the entire release schedule
is designed to avoid major conflicts if
a studio releases two tentpoles on the
same weekend they run the risk of
cannibalizing their own ticket sales so
when you punt one big film to a later
date it often means shifting the big
movie that was originally scheduled for
the second date and so on and so on
according to Variety Disney's new
release schedule includes some major
changes to marvel face for projects
including Black Widow the Eternals Chang
Chi and The Legend of the ten rings
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness and the four Thor movie Thor
love and thunder other big-budget family
flicks like Indiana Jones Five and
Jungle Cruise have also been affected by
the changes though the shuffling of the
MCU appears to be the most significant
repercussion of the rescheduling for
fans and Disney Bowl
blady yeah all right
yes fine what way don't overcorrect as
fans no base board the MCU will kick-off
at Black Widow a prequel flick focusing
on Scarlett Johansson's superspy turned
Avenger
that's still very much the plan but
Black Widow has just been delayed from
its intended May 1st debut all the way
back to November 6 that means phase 4
won't begin until this fall throwing the
entire plan of course it also means that
Black Widow has taken the spots of
another phase 4 staple the Eternals
obviously Disney and Marvel aren't going
to release two movies on the same day so
the Eternals has to move to February 12
2021 the day that shang-chi and the
legend of the ten rings was meant to
open in theaters shifting Black Widow -
what's ostensibly the other available
release date for a Marvel movie has
created a domino effect with each base
for MCU fell now occupying the date that
its successor was initially slotted in
shang-chi will hit cinemas on May 7 2021
followed by the reality bending Doctor
Strange sequel on November 5th 2021
Disney and Marvel gave Thor love and
thunder a totally new release date not
previously listed on the 2020 2021 MCU
scheduled February 18 20 22 so far black
panther 2 is the only base for film that
hasn't been rattled by the change our
second John - the Utopia of Wakanda is
still on the books for May 6 2020 - that
bill will be followed by another direct
sequel Captain Marvel - which is set to
hit theaters on July 8 2022 while these
ships should preserve the MC use hard
rock continuity in some cases they
represent nearly year-long delays what
about the New Mutants you ask well the
news is even worse for fans eagerly
awaiting the x-men's repatriation to the
Marvel canon
especially after 2019 underwhelming Dark
Phoenix after being delayed three times
before the New Mutants has been
postponed indefinitely it joins the
ranks of woman in the window antlers and
the personal history of David
Copperfield all Disney owned projects
currently stranded without her release
dates sure to frustrate fans is the fact
that many of these delayed projects are
already in the can instead of kicking
them to streaming Disney has decided to
hold them back in an attempt to salvage
some kind of theatrical release just how
these changes in the film division may
affect the release schedule on Disney
Plus isn't
early clear but we'll continue to keep
you up-to-date as the situation develops
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff or coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]